[Música]
momento de repasar la prensa
internacional con rosa pérez más de un
rosa bienvenida feliz mañana de martes
rosa abrimos esta revista de prensa en
canadá con la visita del papa- francisco
a este territorio y todos los ojos
puestos en la pérdida del perdón del
papá francisco a los pueblos originarios
o canadienses por este proceso que
hicieron de despojarlos digamos de todas
sus creencias de toda su cultura para
forzosamente hacerlos creer y hacerlos
fieles a una fe católica denuncias de
violación denuncias de maltrato hasta
después gente que murió digamos en todo
este proceso rosa cuando eran unos niños
efectivamente este proceso que se conoce
como asimilación forzosa y en el centro
de toda esta política financiado por el
estado canadiense pero operada dirigida
por organizaciones relacionadas con la
iglesia católica que operaban a
alrededor de unos 140 internados y es se
considera que cerca de 6 mil menores
murió en estos centros que vuelven a
estar como decíamos en el foco del
debate desde que se descubrieran en 2021
unas 1400 tumbas sin nombre sin
identificar precisamente en estos
centros como bien decías donde parece
que las palizas las agresiones sexuales
y el adoctrinamiento la aniquilación
cultural eran una práctica recurrente y
esto fue lo que motivó al papá
finalmente a desplazarse hacia canadá a
pedir perdón no en esta visita de seis
días y ayer tuvo lugar un primer acto
con naciones originarias que hoy ocupa
las portadas de los principales medios
de comunicación
canadienses y hemos seleccionado aquí
tres portadas como veíamos the globe and
the mail que dice lo siento mucho
citando a la papa el papa ofrece una
disculpa histórica a las naciones
originarias a los mestizos e inditex y
pide perdón por la asimilación forzada y
el abuso de los niños indígenas en los
orfanatos el toronto star dice empieza
un nuevo viaje luego destaca los
supervivientes tienen acciones
encontradas respecto a la esperada
visita ahora vamos a entrar precisamente
en las
reacciones a las palabras del pontífice
y el national post dice el papa pide
perdón así de rosas que dentro también
de estas páginas de estos mismos medios
encontramos peticiones de algo más que
un simple perdón no sé si dos a
exactamente esto es lo que señala
precisamente tania tal haga ella es una
miembro de la nación originaria el min
es quien demás caguas is y precisamente
ella señala no reprocha que esta
disculpa del papa no acabo de ser
completa y está muy conmovedor el texto
que ella escribe precisamente en el the
globe and the mail uno de los periódicos
que veían en el anterior gráfico ven
empieza describiendo cuál era el
ambiente no en este acto dice era un día
lluvioso y frío el tiempo acompañaba el
ambiente los espíritus nos hacían saber
que estaban ahí los perdidos no serán
olvidados explica nuestros pueblos
vinieron aquí hoy
a ver si querían estar o no vinieron en
busca de algo de consolación del hombre
vestido con una túnica blanca el hombre
que representa a la iglesia católica la
que arrebató la infancia de nuestros
niños su alegría la luz de sus ojos su
cabello y sus muñecos dice reprocha que
el papá se expresó en su lengua materna
en español y dice algunos de nosotros ya
lo tenemos esta habilidad de este
despojo no está aniquilación cultural
reconoce que es la primera vez que un
pontífice viene a nuestra tierra a
canadá a disculparse no hay que poner la
mirada sobre las tumbas sin nombre dice
que por eso por la emoción del momento
lloramos e incluso el jefe honorario
wilton little side subió a poner un
tocado una corona de las naciones
originarias el máximo reconocimiento
sobre la cabeza del papá no dice el papá
francisco vino a disculparse por un
genocidio no lo mencionó y aún así le
dimos un tocado nuestro amor no tiene
límites lamenta eso sí que el papá no se
disculpará por toda la iglesia sino
solamente por algunos miembros y dice
las disculpas no llegará a los niños
muertos a los que se suicidaron oa los
que fueron víctimas de un infierno en su
propia casa porque sus familiares
supervivientes descargaron su angustia
sobre los que más amaban y termina
diciendo como naciones originarias
sabemos que la iglesia católica no nos
salvará lo que nos salvará es mirar
hacia los nuestros y redescubrir nuestra
espiritualidad lo que nos salva es
nuestro lenguaje nuestras ceremonias y
no obtendremos la paz de un hombre de
blanco